[Music]
philosophers dramatists theologians have
grappled with this question for
centuries what makes people go wrong
interestingly I asked this question when
I was a little kid when I was a kid
growing up in the South Bronx inner-city
ghetto in New York I was surrounded by
evil as all kids are who grow up in an
inner city and I had friends who were
really good kids
who lived out the dr. Jekyll mr. Hyde
scenario of Robert Louis Stevenson that
is they took drugs got in trouble went
to jail some got killed and some did it
without drug assistance so when I read
Robert Louis Stevenson
but that was in fiction the only
question is what was in the juice and
more importantly that line between good
and evil which privilege people like to
think is fixed and impermeable with them
on the good side and the others on the
bad side I knew that line was immovable
and it was permeable good people could
be seduced across that line and on the
good sand some rare circumstances bad
kids could recover with help with reform
with rehabilitation so I want to begin
with it's wonderful it's wonderful
illusion by Swiss artist MC Escher if
you look at it and focus on the white
what you see is a world full of angels
but let's look more deeply and as we do
what appears is the demons The Devil's
in the world and that tells us several
things one the world is was will always
be filled with good and evil there's
good and evil is the yin and yang of the
human condition tells me something else
if you remember God's favorite angel was
Lucifer
apparently Luther means the light it
also means the morning star in some
scripture and apparently he disobeyed
God and that's the ultimate disobedience
to authority and when he did Michael the
Archangel was sent to kick him out of
heaven along with the other fallen
angels and so Lucifer descends into hell
becomes Satan becomes the devil the
force of evil in the universe begins
paradoxically it was God who created
hell as a place to store evil he didn't
do a good job of keeping it there though
so this arc of the cosmic transformation
of God's favorite angel into the devil
for me sets the context or under
human beings who are transformed from
good ordinary people into perpetrators
of evil so the loser effect although it
focuses on the negatives the negatives
that people can become not the negatives
that people are leads me to a
psychological definition evil is the
exercise of power and that's the key
it's about power
to intentionally harm people
psychologically to hurt people
physically to destroy people mortally or
ideas and to commit crimes against
humanity if you google evil a word that
should truly have with it by now you
come up with a hundred and thirty six
million hits and a third of a second a
few years ago I'm sure all of you was
shocked as I was with the revelation of
American soldiers abusing prisoners in a
strange place in a controversial war I
would grab and in Iraq and these were
men and women who were putting prisons
through an unbelievable humiliation I
was shocked that I wasn't surprised
because I had seen those same visual
parallels when I was the prison
superintendent of the Stanford Prison
study immediately the Bush
administration military said what what
all administration's say when there's a
scandal don't blame us it's not the
system it's the few bad apples a few
rogue soldiers my hypothesis is American
soldiers are good usually maybe it was
the Powell that was bad but how am I
gonna how I gonna deal with that
hypothesis I became an expert witness
for one of the guards sergeant chip
Frederick and in that position I had
access to the dozen investigative
reports I had access to him I could
study him have him come to my home get
to know him do psychological analysis to
see was he a good apple or bad Apple and
thirdly I had access to all of the
thousand pictures that these soldiers
took these pictures are a violent or
sexual nature all of them come from the
cameras of American soldiers because
everybody has the digital cameras cell
phone camera they took pictures of
everything more than a thousand what
I've done is I organized them into
various categories but these are by
United States Military Police Army
reservists there are not soldiers
prepared for this mission at all
and it all happened in single place Toa
on the night shift why tRNA was the
Center for military intelligence
it was the interrogation hold CIA was
there interrogators from Titan
corporation all there and they're
getting no information about the
insurgency so they're gonna put pressure
on these soldiers military police to
cross the line give them permission to
break it with the will of the enemy to
prepare them for interrogation to soften
them up to take the gloves off those are
the euphemisms and this is how it was
interpreted let's go down to that
dungeon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so pretty horrific that's what that's
one of the one of the visual
illustration of evil and it should not
have escaped you that the reason I
paired that the prisoner with his arms
out with Leonardo da Vinci's Oh to
humanity is that that prison that was
mentally ill that prison had covered
himself with [ __ ] every day and they
used to have to roll him in dirt so he
wouldn't stink but but the guards ended
up calling him [ __ ] boy what was he
doing in that prison rather than in some
mental institution in any event here's
former Secretary of Defense Rumsfeld he
comes down and says I want to know who
is responsible who are the bad screw the
bad apples well that's a bad question
you have to reframe it and ask what is
responsible because what could be the
who of people but it could also be the
want of the situation and obviously
that's where I'm headed so how does
psychologists go about understanding
such transformations of human character
if you believe that they were good
soldiers before they went down to the
dungeons there are three ways the main
way is what's called dispositional we
look at what's inside of the person the
bad apples this is the foundation of all
of social sciences foundation of a
religion the foundation of law social
psychologists like me come along saying
yeah people are the actors on the stage
but you'll have to be aware of what the
situation is who are the cast of
characters what's the costume is there a
sage director and so we're interested in
what are the external factors around the
individual the bad barrel and social
scientists stop there and they missed
the big point that I discovered when I
was became an experienced tribal grab
the power is in the system the system
creates the situation that corrupts the
individuals the system is the legal
political economic cultural background
and this is where the power is of the
bad barrel makers so you want to change
the person you got to change the
situation one change the situation you
got to know where the power is in the
system so the loser effect involves
understanding human character
transformations with these three factors
and it's a dynamic interplay what did
the people bring into the situation what
is the situation bring out of them
and what is the system that that creates
and maintains that situation so my book
the loser in fact recently published is
about how do you understand how good
people turn evil and it has great a lot
of detail about what I'm going to talk
about today
so dr. Z's loser effect although focuses
on evil really is a celebration of the
human minds infinite capacity to make
any of us kinda cruel caring or
indifferent creative or destructive and
it makes some of us villains and the
good news story that I'm going to
hopefully come to at the end is that
makes some of us heroes this is a
wonderful cartoon in The New Yorker
which really summarizes my whole talk
I'm neither a good cop bad cop to Rome
like yourself I'm a complex amount I'm a
positive negative personality traits
that emerge or not depending on the
circumstances does it study some of you
think you know about but very few people
have ever read the story you watch you
watch the movie this is a Stanley
Milgram little Jewish kid from the Bronx
and he asked the question could the
Holocaust happen here now you say no
that's not see Germany that's Hitler
you know that's 1939 said yeah but
suppose Hitler asked you would you
electrocute a stranger no way not me I'm
a good person said why don't we put you
in a situation and give you a chance to
see what you would do and so what he did
was he tested a thousand ordinary people
500 New Haven Connecticut 540 and the ad
said psychologists want to understand
memory we want to improve people's
memory because memory is a key to
success okay we're going to give you
five bucks four dollars for your time
we don't want to college students we
want men between 20 and 50 and latest
studies there in women
ordinary people barbers clerks
white-collar people so you go down and
one of you is going to be alert and one
of you is going to be teacher to learn
is a genial middle-aged guy he gets tied
up to the shock apparatus in another
room the learner could be the
middle-aged could be as young as 20 and
one of you is told by the authority the
guy in the lab coat your job as teacher
is to give this guy material to learn
gets the right reward and gets it wrong
you press a button on the shock box
first button is 15 volts he doesn't even
feel it that's the key all evil starts
with 15 volts and then
step there's another 15 volts the
problem is at the end of the line is 450
volts and actually go along the height
is screaming I got a heart condition I'm
out of here you're a good person you
complain sir who's gonna be responsible
something happens him experiment says
don't worry I will be responsible go
continue teacher and the question is who
would go all the way to 450 volts you
should notice here when it gets up to
375 is dangerous to be a shock when it
gets up to here this xxx the pornography
of power so Milgram has 40 psychiatrist
helmet what percent of American citizen
who go to the end they said only 1%
because that sadistic behavior and we
know psychiatry knows only 1% of
Americans are sadistic ok here's the
data they could not be more wrong 2/3 go
all the way to 450 volts this was just
one study Milgram did more than 16
studies and look at this in study 16
where you see somebody like you go all
the way 90 percent go all the way and
study 5 if you see people rebelled 90
percent rebelled
what about women study 13 no different
than men so Milgram is quantifying evil
as the willingness of people to blindly
obey Authority through all the way to 40
50 volts and it's like a dial on human
nature a dialing sense that you can make
almost everybody totally obedient down
to the majority down to none so what are
the external parallels for all research
is artificial what's the validity in
real world 912 American citizens
committed suicide or murdered by family
and friends in Guyana jungle in 1978
because they were blindly obedient to
the sky a pastor not the priest a pastor
Reverend Jim Jones he persuaded them to
commit mass suicide and so he's the
modern loose effect a man of God who
becomes the angel of death Milgram study
is all about individual authority to
control people most of the time we are
in institutions so the Stanford Prison
study is a study of the power of
institutions to influence individual
behavior interestingly Stanley Milgram
and I were in the same high school class
in James Munroe in the Bronx 1954
so this study which I did with my
graduate students especially Craig Haney
we also began with an ad we didn't have
money so we had cheap little head but we
wanted college students for a study of
prison life seventy-five people behind
here took personality tests we did
interviews pick two dozen most normal
most healthy randomly assign them to a
prison guard so on day one we knew we
had good apples I'm gonna put them in a
bad situation and secondly we know
there's no difference between the boys
who are going to be guards the boys of
entry prisons the kids are going to be
friends you said wait at home in the
dormitories what the study will begin
Sunday we didn't tell them that the city
police were going to come and do
realistic arrests
police car pulls up in front and a cop
comes to the front door knocks and says
he's looking for me so they right there
that you know they took me out the door
they put my hands against the car
there's a real cop car it was a real
policeman and there were real neighbors
in the street who didn't know that I was
that this was a experiment and there was
cameras all around the neighbors all
around but they put me in the car then
they drove me around Palo Alto they took
me to the to the police station the
basement of the police station
then they put me in a Cell I was the
first one to be picked up so they put me
in a cell which is just like a room with
a door with bars on it
you could tell it wasn't a real jail
they locked me in there than this
degrading little outfit they were taking
this experiment too seriously
here are the prisoners who are going to
be dehumanized they're going to become
numbers here the guards with the symbols
of power and anonymity guards get
prisons to clean the toilet bowls out
their bare hands to do all the
humiliating tasks they strip them naked
they sexually taunt them they begin to
do degrading activities like having them
simulate sodomy you saw simulating
fellatio in soldiers novigrad my guards
did it in five days the express reaction
was so extreme that normal kids we've
picked because they're healthy had
breakdowns within 36 hours the study
ended after six days because it had was
out of control five kids had emotional
breakdown does it make a difference if
warriors go to battle changing their
appearance or not does it make a
difference if they're anonymous and how
they treat their victims we know in some
cultures they go to war they don't
change their parents in other cultures
they paint themselves like Lord of the
Flies and some they wear masks and many
they wear soldiers are anonymous and
uniform
so with this psycho anthropologist John
Watson found 23 cultures that had do
bits of data so they changed their
appearance 15 do they kill torture
mutilate 13 if they don't change their
appearance only one of eight kills
torture mutilate the key is in the red
zone if they change their appearance 12
of 13 that's 90 percent kill torture
mutilation and that's the power of
anonymity so what are the seven social
processes at grease the slippery slope
of evil mindlessly taking the first
small step dehumanization of others the
intimidation of self diffusion of
personal responsibility blind obedience
to Authority uncritical conformity to
group norms passive tolerance of evil
through inaction or indifference and it
happens when you're in a new or
unfamiliar situation your habitual
response patterns don't work your
personality and morality are disengaged
nothing is easier than to denounce the
evil doer nothing more difficult than
understanding him Dostoevsky tells us
understanding is not excusing psychology
is not excuse e ology so social
psychological research reveals how
ordinary good people can be transformed
without the drugs you don't need it you
just see the social psychological
processes real-world parallels compare
this
with this James Schlesinger and I'm
gonna have to end with this says
psychologists have attempted to
understand how and why individuals and
groups who usually act humanely can
sometimes act otherwise in certain
circumstances
that's the looser effect and he goes on
to say the landmark stanford study
provides a cautionary tale for all
military operations if you give people
power without oversight it's a
prescription for abuse they knew that
and let that happen
so another another report investigative
report by General Fay says the system is
guilty and in this report he says it was
the environment created Abu Ghraib by
leadership failures that contribute to
the occurrence of such abuse and the
fact that it remained undiscovered by
higher authorities for a long period
time those abuses went on for three
months who was watching the store the
answer is nobody and I think nobody on
purpose you gave the guards permission
to do those things and they knew nobody
was ever going to come down to that
dungeon so you need a paradigm shift in
all these areas the shift is away from
the medical model that focused only on
the individual and that the shift is
toward a public health model that
recognizes situational and systemic
vectors of disease bullying is a disease
prejudices disease violence is disease
and since the Inquisition we've been
dealing with problems at the individual
level and you know what it doesn't work
Alexander Solzhenitsyn says the line
between good and evil cuts through the
heart of every human being that means
that line is not out there that's a
decision that you have to make that's a
personal thing so I want end very
quickly on a positive note heroism as
the antidote to evil by promoting the
heroic imagination especially in our
kids in an educational system we want
kids to think I'm a hero in waiting
waiting for the right situation to come
along and I will act heroically my whole
life is now going to focus away from
evil I've been in since I was a kid to
understanding heroes banality of heroism
is odd it's ordinary people who do
heroic deeds
it's the counterpoint to Haaretz a
banality of evil our traditional
societal heroes are wrong because they
they are the exceptions they organize
the whole life around this that's why we
know the names and our kids heroes are
also wrong models for them because they
have supernatural talents we want our
kids to realize most heroes and everyday
people and the heroic act is unusual
this is Joe Darby he was the one that
stopped though
abuses who saw because what he saw those
images he turned them over to see an
investigating officer he was a low-level
private and that stopped it was a hero
no they had put him in hiding because
people wanted to kill him and then his
mother and his wife for three years they
were in hiding this is the woman who
stopped the stamp of prison said and I
said it got out of control I was a
prison superintendent I didn't notice
out of control
I was totally indifferent she came down
sore that had house and said you know
what
it's terrible what you're doing for
those boys not presidents they're not
cards they're boys and you are
responsible and I ended the study the
next day the good news is I married for
the next year
I just came to my senses obviously so so
situations have the power to do suit the
sick but it's the point this is the same
situation that can inst it that can
inflame the hostile imagination some of
us that makes us perpetrators of evil
can inspire the heroic imagination
others it's the same situation and
you're on one side or the other
most people are guilty of the evil of
inaction because your mother says don't
get involved mind your own business and
um say mama
humanity is my business so it's that
College of heroines and menaces we're
gonna end in a moment how do we
encourage children and new hero courses
that I'm working with Matt Langdon he
has a hero workshop to develop this
heroic imagination is self labeling I am
a hero in waiting and teach them skills
to be a hero you have to learn to be a
deviant because you're always going
against the conformity of the group
heroes are ordinary people who social
actions extraordinary who act the key to
heroes of two things you had act when
other people have passive be you have
that socio centrically not egocentric
Lee and I want to end with the story
that some of you know about Wesley
Autrey
New York subway hero 50 year old
african-american construction worker
he's standing on a subway in New York a
white guy falls on the tracks the subway
train is coming there's 75 people there
you know what they freeze he's got a
reason not to get involved he's black
the guy's wife and he's got two little
kids instead he gives his kids to
strange it jumps on the tracks puts the
guy between the tracks lays on him the
subway goes over him Wesley in the guy
20 and a half inches height the Train
clearance is 21 inches a half an inch
would have taken his head off and he
said I did what anyone could do no big
deal to jump in the tracks and the moral
imperative is I did what everyone should
do and so one day you will be in a new
situation take path one you're gonna be
a perpetrator of evil evil meaning I'm
gonna be Arthur Andersen you want to
cheat so you're gonna have to allow
bullying that's who you become guilty of
the evil passive in action pass through
you become a hero the point is are we
ready to take the path to celebrating
ordinary heroes waiting for the right
situation to come along to put heroic
imagination into action because it may
only happen once in your life when you
pass it by you'll always know I could
have been a hero and let it pass me by
so the point is thinking it and then do
so I want to thank you thank you thank
you let's suppose the power of evil
systems at home and abroad and let's
focus on the positive advocate for
respective personal dignity for justice
and peace which sadly our administration
has not been doing thanks so much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]